you know i've been
hanging out with the cool with other
group of weirdos
uh lately michael malus who's uh
who espouses to be an anarchist
anarchism
which is like i i think intellectually
just a
fascinating set of ideas uh where
the you know taking free market to the
full extreme of
basically saying there should be no no
government
what is it uh oversight i guess and then
everything should be
fully like all the agreements all the
collectives you form should be
uh voluntary not based on the
geographic land you were born on and so
on do you think
that's just the giant mess like do you
think it's possible for an anarchist
society to work
where it's um you know this in a dis
in a fully distributed way people agree
with each other not just
on financial transactions but you know
on
um on their personal security
on sort of military type of stuff uh on
health care
on education all those kinds of things
and where does it break down
well i wouldn't press a button to say
get rid of our current constitution
which i view is pretty good
and quite wise but i think the deeper
point is that
all societies are in some regards
anarchistic yes and we should take the
anarchist seriously so globally there's
a kind of anarchy
across borders even within federalistic
systems
they're typically complex there's not a
clear transitivity
necessarily of who has the final say
over what
uh just the state visa via its people
there's not
per se a final arbitrator in that regard
so you want a good anarchy rather than a
bad anarchy
you want to squish your anarchy into the
right corners and i don't think there's
a theoretical
answer how to do it but you start with a
country like is it working
well enough now this country you'd say
mostly
you'd certainly want to make a lot of
improvements and that's why i don't want
to press that get rid of the
constitution button
but to just dump on the anarchists is to
miss the point always try to learn
from any opinion you know what in it is
true
i i'm just like uh marveling at the at
the poetry of
saying that we should squish our anarchy
into the right corners
love it
you